i'll block the alley from the street
tommy you handled the rest of them
and you secure the weapons what about
kenta he's mine
they're here
uh
boys
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
uh
all right
cobra
this is a lot of firepower
i'll just keep him on with it all
to start a war
with us
which means we're gonna need support
let's call scarlet
give me a second
i need to take care of some surprise
guests
go ahead
kenda is back in tokyo
and aligning with cobra
this is recent
from tonight
hang on a second
[Music]
should we be worried
about scarlet no
major herder is with the jokes
what an elite global counter-terrorism
unit
they're the good guys
cobra supposed to do with cobra
the deal is there a secret network of
terrorist cells crime syndicates arms
manufacturers and paramilitary groups
links under a single centralized command
a shadow organization devoted to
bringing about global revolution through
violence extortion and fear
major i just sent you a mission brief
i've been keeping tapped on an old
friend of mine who just landed in japan
i don't think it's a coincidence
her name's anna de cobra aka baroness
since we lost touch she's been busy
she killed a member of parliament
along with 200 other passengers on the
same train just to influence an election
she's been linked to bombings
assassinations and civil unrest
everywhere from nanzaya to borovia in
short she's top echelon cobra if kent is
linked up with the baroness the threat
to you is significant i'll be in tokyo
as soon as i can
you